خطط المعارضين لصفقه بايدن مكارسي
المتعلقه بسقف الدين فشلت في اخماد مشروع
القانون في مهده فتشريع اجتاز عقبه مهمه
بعد اقراره من قبل لجنه القواعد بواقع
سبعه اصوات مقابل سته لجنه القواعد ارسلت
تشريع الى مجلس النواب بكامل هيئته لبحثي
والتصويت عليه اليوم واذا ما اقره مجلس
النواب الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون
فسيحيله الى مجلس الشيوخ لبحثه والتصويت
عليه ايضا مشروع القانون يقضي بتعليق سقف
الدين البالغ
31.4 ترليون دولار حتى اول يناير 2025 كما
يضع حدا لبعض الانفاق الحكومي على مدار
العامين المقبلين يسرع عمليه الموافق على
بعض مشروعات الطاقه ويعيد اموال مكافحه
كورونا غير المستخدمه يتعين ان يقر
الكونغرس بمجلسي هذا التشريع قبل الخامس
من يونيو حينها قد تعجز الولايات المتحده
عن سداد ديونها لاول مره في تاريخها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات